first of all uh congratulations thank
you for being here you are pregnant with
your second child yes how far along are
you I'm a little over six months oh my
goodness yes I I just I was just
thinking right now we called you out and
the band is playing and I don't know if
that makes the baby flip around or no
quiet right now quiet right now yeah the
baby wakes up just as I'm going to sleep
oh good yeah it's perfect so when things
are raucous the baby's asleep yeah now
I'm just curious you have such beautiful
red hair does your first child have oh
thank you
could you excuse us uh
does your first child have red hair no
he's white blonde yeah and my husband
has brown hair okay it was the red hair
jean is very squirrely I have red hair
my wife does not and both of my children
have blonde blonde blonde blonde whitish
hair yeah yeah that which is which is
weird I mean it's like they you know
people I I I'm used to growing up in a
family where we were all redheads your
dad's a famous famous those famous
television redheads of all time right
Howard yeah well second
[Applause]
I think he's first uh but here's the
thing it's been this story has been in
the news this week I don't know if you
how you react to this but sperm banks
are now turning down red-headed donors
because nobody wants to have red-headed
babies did you hear this I take this so
personally of course you do they don't
want any more of us that's the worst
it's the worst thing I ever heard yeah
that's the worst thing ever the Netflix
thing is really bad
nothing compares to that but um but
that's a true story that's real that's I
mean that's really that's really
confronting I there's a part of me that
understands
because we're not really built for
planet Earth we go outside once and then
we spend the next five years in the
dermatologist office like getting things
lasered off
you know it's yeah I did have a
dermatologist once say to me this is a
true story he said what do you do when
you uh go to the beach and I said I wear
a big hat I put on like 50 sunblock I
put on a long sleeve shirt and he said
yes but what else do you do
maybe you want to stay home
I felt like the kid from Powder it's
crazy yeah yeah I mean both my parents
are redheads and both of their parents
were redheads so we're genetically like
messed up I mean it's like almost like
an inbred sort of thing we have all I
love it when you tell this story don't
they
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's a little comforting because my
husband is you know very
appears very differently than I and and
so it was sort of it was sort of good to
get some new genes into the gene pool
into the Howard gene pool well I will
say this I think women with red hair are
beautiful and stunning I think men with
red hair it's like oh you know I'm just
being really honest that's why I do my
best to look like a woman
I think red-headed women are gorgeous my
red-headed guys it's like what's going
on with the Viking over there
my my mother would strongly disagree
okay obviously yeah she's just she
thinks redheaded guys are really hot I
mean she's been with my dad since they
were 16. so yeah but my parents actually
they um
they kind of debate this issue because
they they were both made fun of a lot
when they were kids you know redheads
are kind of made fun of and they they
all you know they kind of talk about who
was ostracized more for being a redhead
right I mean it was my dad
he got picked on more yeah yeah
definitely and pushed him over yeah
and balding when he was like 21. yeah
yeah which is but he's done fine yeah
yeah he's stuck yeah I think he squeaked
through